bonjour et bienvenue sur diagonale tv
championnat du monde d'échecs féminin
2016 avec donc dit fan ou la chinoise
face à l'ukrainienne maria musi tchouk
septième partie la chinoise mène de deux
points face à l'ukrainienne il reste à
peine donc trois parties dans un match
en 10 c'est la septième alors c'est
parti
on va voir si maria mozy tout cas avec
et noir peut réaliser un exploit il
faudrait parce qu'après marqué deux
points dans les deux dernières parties
ça va quand même être un tout petit peu
un tout petit peu difficile mais
pourquoi pas pourquoi pas un tout est
possible bien sûr alors eu quatre ou
cinq donc la classique
les fins de revient sur son ouverture du
match à la elle a quasiment tout le
temps jouer ça je crois qu'une seule
fois elle a joué par par l'ouverture du
pion dame donc ici krief 3 kbc 6 et donc
la rue lopez elle varie pas un toujours
l'armée lopez alors est-ce qu'on va
avoir droit de nouveau à l'espagnol
ouverte qui avait valu sa première
défaite à marjah musique joue qu'avec
les noirs on va voir ce qu'elle va jouer
à 6 rien apparemment pour l'instant sa
lettre ça suit le même court x 4 kalyev
six attaques le pion central petit rock
on n'a pas peur de la prison centrale
mais les noirs prennent quand même et
enfin des cats voilà c'est la même même
variante pour la troisième je crois
troisième fois
lifan joue contre l'espanyol ouverte de
mariam ou zouk b5 fougue et trois des
cinq c'est qu'on les a déjà vus puis on
prend 1,5 faut 6 voilà tout ça a été
déjà vu je vous invite à avoir les
parties précédentes ou dit fan ou à
jouer
cette même ouverture avec les blancs et
où maria mais je voulais même coup et
akalé d2 alors je crois qu'à valider de
la c1 une simple c'est un nouveau coup
on avait essayé il me semble non fouet
trois essais trois aussi alors ça ça
varie un peu assez mais quand même c'est
la ccc une vraie variation sur lequel on
peut pas jouer forcément toujours les
mêmes coûts en face
voilà ça n'a l'air de rien mais c'est
des petites différences qui peuvent fin
qui peuvent être importantes
déjà on menace de prendre quatre avec ce
cavalier puis après peut-être la
présence 6
et si les noirs sont obligés de
reprendre par exemple eh bien on aurait
un pion aux six très mal placé et puis 1
4 qui sera repris plus tard et on aurait
une mauvaise structure c'est possible
donc il faut faire attention aux fausses
est pas de problème pour l'instant et c3
alors c'est 3 à l'idée du soukouss
étroits ce qu'elle n'en veulent pas tout
à fait prendre tout de suite même si bon
pour une envisagées on peut jamais on
peut toujours envisager sur le coup mais
un an après la reprise sur un supra en
prendrait peut-être d'abord le cas bien
f3 et le foot attaque et ça c'est
classique
c'est un premier point est là le coup
ces trois îles et du fait du coup
suivant des noirs voilà câblée c5n
maintenant les noirs recul plutôt que de
faire le rock la cie en k2 rock si on
peut se demander si le coup football
c'est pas fou ces deux sans doute
alors là bien sûr on attaque le fou et
on veut pas donner ce magnifique fou
contre le cavalier ce fou et très fort
pour le côté blanc puisque ici regardez
tous ses pions sur noir donc ce fou
complète l'action des pions il faudrait
pas le lâcher c'est un flux important
donc fou ces deux là c'est un fou très
important et la paire de fou dans ce
type d'opposition vous voyez où ça peut
s'ouvrir par à 4 très vite et où elle
est allée elle est crucial il faut la
garder au père de foot cette fameuse
perdre fou qui permet d'agir à distance
c'est la force des fous par rapport aux
cavaliers sont un peu plus longs en
attaque et on le colle et à d'autres
avantages et dans d'autres types
d'oppositions
voilà des quatre ans leurs classiques
ici voilà les noirs bien ce se décide à
pousser au centre tant que c'est
possible pour pour faire des échanges
essayé de simplifier la position puis on
prend cavaliers prend cavaliers prends
tu t'en prends tout ça et tout ça y est
tout ça est tout à fait jouable bien
entendu qu à bf3 tap la dame et voilà on
prend tout simplement et tout reprend
voilà déjà on est dans une finale les
dames sont échangées pour pas dire
qu'ils attaquent sur les rock ou sur les
rois donc bon on est vraiment là tout de
suite dans une quasi finale petit rock
et la voilà classique fouet trois se
fout souvent développé en trois dans
cette position dans cette ouverture on a
déjà vu aussi alors voilà on va voir
essayer maintenant de voir que le
quelles peuvent être les plans il
semblerait là que les que le noir est
quand même bien simplifié
est ce que les blancs peuvent tirer
avantage futile position je ne sais pas
tour des huit voilà propose déjà de
contester en compte est la colonne des
on propose un échange de taux plus des
plus il ya des changes est plus facile
pour les noirs d'annuler enfin en tout
cas de simplifier alors attention parce
qu'en finale ici il ya quand même un
ministre au point qu'il faut relever
c'est qu'ici on a trois pions non contre
2 là j'avais signé l'a signalé sans les
parties précédentes
on a enfin ici une possibilité de finale
asymétrique trois pions contre 2 et là
on a quatre pions ici contre 3 donc ça
veut dire que ces trois pions contre 2
si on les pousse et qu'on fait des gens
l'on peut se retrouver qu'un pion pas
c'est donc là qui peut menacer de
farnham donc il existe cette position
plus de chances de gains que dans une
position où les structures sont deux
pions sont les mêmes voilà parce que ils
ont peu on peut créer des
on peut créer des tensions sur rue sur
une aile ou sur l'autre et ça pose plus
de problème voilà donc c'est un peu un
concept ça qu'il faut garder en tête
voilà d'avoir des structures de pions
asymétrique augmente les possibilités de
gains à la tour c alors ça c'est ça
c'est alors ça c'est un coup de grands
maîtres
moi j'adore ce coup donc on refuse les
changes et surtout on met la tour ici
regardez paf sur la colonne qui
justement attaque le pion c7 ma mine de
rien ce pion il y arriérés pour
l'instant puisqu'il peut pas être
défendue par un autre pion il faudrait
qu'ils poussent en c5 et qu'ils puissent
venir en c4 pour ne pas être un pur
arrière il faudrait qu'ils sont assez
simples quoi voilà pour de pouvoir
avancer être protégé par son pion b5
mais il arrière et donc on pourrait
envisager si les noirs jouent des coûts
un peu poussif
s'ils font pas attention de monter une
pression sur la colonne c est de poser
de gros problèmes aux noirs sur ce pion
c7 alors à noter si lifan ou et bien
gagné cette partie le championnat
s'arrête tout de suite pourquoi pas
l'arrêter tout de suite et éviter
d'avoir à jouer une partie de plus h 6 h
six mois ça fait rien seront sur la
colonne s'est en tout cas mais ça enlève
la case g5 pour les blancs ce dernier
blanc peut pas jouer ni fou g5 ni
cavaliers g5 les g5 qui est toujours un
peu embêtant ça tacle fou aussi ce
qu'est ce qu'on fait avec ce fou et si
on donne le foot case noirs les blancs
sont contents avec la paire de fou il
aurait eu là de vraies chances de gain
père de fou on peut en chasser cet
arriéré attention les cartes seraient
dans les mains d
non non c'est pas envisager mon htc un
coup solide positionnelle on enlève la
case g5 jamais de calais j'essaie ni de
foule et 5
voilà c'est un coup logique et en plus
gros on a toujours un petit fenêtre pour
le roi ou cas où on sait jamais mais
c'est surtout pour contrôler 7 kg s'est
calé des quatre ont alors vu qu'on peut
pas aller en jeu c'est qu'on vient en d4
attention menace d'aller prendre le faux
6 donc fou des cinq voiliers qu'on
laisse pas la paire de fou et puis
surtout on met le fou sur une belle
diagonale à voilà qui contrôle les cases
centrale voilà bon j'ai deux là il n'y a
pas d' attaque sur leurs ouailles à plus
d'un moment ça va être difficile mais il
est bien placé se fout il est au centre
solide pas de problème la foudre a bon
un coup un coup un peu poussif celui-là
ça me fait penser au fond de 2,2 de
mariée amouzou que la partie précédente
là à son cou de fou qui était quand même
un peu plus cif qui on a vu servait pas
grand chose au final
la food et un là aussi ça me paraît
moins faiblard ici on n'a plus envie de
jouer éventuellement pourquoi pas un fou
et f5 pour mettre le faut sur cette
diagonale a comme son contrôle ces huit
oran s'est vite on a envie de mettre une
tour pour con pour protéger la colonne
s'est donc si on met le fou sur cf c'est
moi j'aime mieux je préfère ce coup au
moins il est actif il est il est en jeu
là en plus on garde le contrôle de la
case d3 contre le cavalier tout de suite
ou alors s'il est normal c'est de
chasser le fou pour sortir le bon
affaiblit un peu les droits déjà et un
problème sur le pion aux 6 voilà donc
fou et 5t plus active voire même cavalli
et 5,5 on rêve toujours de maître
d'école 900 c'est toujours bien et
s'attaque le fou il sera obligé d'aller
ensuite bon cavalier bon qui sera absent
10 de chasse et donc tarn aimant et ça
va être plutôt tard d'ailleurs parce que
pas facile
on peut pas jouer ici sillage 6 qui sera
en prise du fou et du cavalier bon bref
il ya des coups actifs
notre quoi bon elle joue fou d'ailleurs
bon ceci dit fou de al'avantage de
libérer l'action sur ces 7 bien et
regarder la réponse de noir c'est bien
joué
calais des trois superbes j'ai pas peur
c'était pas évident j'ai pas peur de
donner le pion c7
donc si un sacrifice que nous fait marié
musique zouk et c'est un bon sacrifices
on peut dire que là les noirs ont réussi
leurs débuts et on commence commencent à
obtenir une position égal dès le 19e
coup là c'est égal au moins égaler puis
on peut dire même bahia c'est un peu
triki elle est un peu dangereux il ya un
peu des pièges dans ses positions
à noter que j'attaque ou 6.5 s'attaque 5
j'attaque la tour j'attaque b2 voilà
c'est pour ça que j'aime pas le coût d
un séquence l'hyper passif bon ça libère
l'action de la tour d'être elle voulait
mettre son fonds g4 en ce cas là
pourquoi pas jouer tout de suite fleuve
5 et inciter les noirs à pousser leurs
pions de la loi ce qui crée des troncs 1
ski parce qu'on aurait pu être
intéressant bon voilà temps dans bel ami
fan a des problèmes alors qu'est ce
qu'on fait d'un subtil de positions
souvent comme ça qu'un tir est un pion à
prendre sadc un peu compliqué il vaut
mieux prendre le pion et se dire bon
mais les noirs vont récupérer et à la
fesse à ce sera au moins égal quoi parce
que si on commence à essayer de défensif
là là on va voir des gros problèmes face
on n'a pas trop le choix
il ya trop de pièces attaquer donc il
faut prendre le pion donc cette
combinaison force une simplification qui
augmente après fouet fuite
il ya toujours attention b2 et cède
alors si on laisse prendre b2 il y aura
toujours deux pions contre un sur l'ale
et le pion aux cinq restera attaqué un
taux de 6 heures il faudrait jouer un
coup comme f4 c'est possible si on vous
le gardez au 5 mai on lâcherait b2 qui
plus est le fousseret attaquer tout de
suite escalier une superbe kazan c4 où
il coupe
l'action de la tour qui se retrouve un
peu enfermé dans le camp ennemi et qui
pourrait pourquoi pas se faire prendre
avec des manoeuvres longue mais jouable
on pourrait l'attaqué avec le fou à
jouer à tour fawcett fou des 8es où va
la tour en voilà elle peut pas sortir
quoi sur les baies deux c4 tu fais une
superbe casse complètement indélogeable
ce cavalier
bref donc non elle joue aussi ce c16
d'abord l'idée c'est de dire c'est ce
pion que je donne et pas b2 et là si tu
prends b2b évident tu vas perdre f7 ce
qui affaiblit le roi puis on prend un
set peut-être même qu'on peut faire tour
premier set je sais pas sans doute on
peut faire trop prendre cette revue
imaginons que les mails et noir font
cavalier prendre b2 pourquoi pas ici
ah non il ya pire mes blessures ont joué
sept tout simplement grosse fourche est
donc voilà on ne peut pas on n'a pas le
choix et voilà il faut il faut sur six
il n'y a pas le choix faut prendre ce
plan comprend le pion donc ça c'est
intéressant ça c'est là aussi c'est un
coup de maître puisque maintenant il
joue fou des cadres actifs menace
d'aller récupérer aussi ce en prenant
attaquant la tour et le fouet si le fou
prend je prends avec échec et j'ai la
paire de fou et là c'est moins gênant
d'avoir deux pions contre 1 1 quand
c'est moins que la paire de fou parce
que là du coup je avec deux fous et les
tours comme sarah dans ce type de
position il ya un cavalier je peux
monter les attaques contre le roi qui
devient faible
regardez comme il a plu beaucoup de
cases le fou de cases blanches devient
énorme et tout mon bref c'est très très
très très dangereux
donc les noirs ne laisse pas faire tours
il protège ce petit pion au cynisme
voire et là on comprend mieux l'idée de
huy fans dans cette partie maintenant
les trois maintenant à ce moment-là
mettront donc on n'a pas joué b3 tout de
suite on a d'abord jocistes parce
qu'évidemment il faut comprendre que si
on avait joué b3 les noirs avaient
repris le pion à 1,5
la structure des pions mois aurait été
bonne or que la et les moins bonnes mais
les mauvaises c'est une mauvaise
structure donc là et un petit avantage
blanc du fait de la structure qui plus
est si c'est possible de jouer un coup
comme tour ici attaque le cavalier et
puis après d'arriver à remettre la tour
en c1 et de super contrôler la colonne
s'est non seulement les noirs une petite
faiblesse mais en plus ils n'ont pas la
colonne ouverte
bon ceci dit ça va être ça va être en
noir de jouer et on va pas laisser faire
un fou des quatre fous pardon food et 6
là tout de suite voilà je question de la
tour donc on va pas rester longtemps ces
sept là ça va pas être ça
ça va pas le faire si si alors si on
joue un coup comme tour 17 c'est
possible c'est possible aurait pu tenter
tour 17
dans ce cas là le fou serait allé très
certainement eu 5 qui cloue le cas les
d4 ici sur la tour on aurait joué la
tour sans doute en d1 des choses comme
ça il n'y a pas de risque en des classes
est protégé par le foot mais surtout le
fou en venant ensuite en contrôler ses
sept donc il y aura jamais de doublement
sur la septième contre le bien bien le
centre pour avec les noirs comme pour
ses 2es la up call you think pas mal bon
on le cavaillon sait qu'il restera pas
indéfiniment des trois quoique on aurait
pu laisser ici encore longtemps des
trois repas mais il restera pas
indéfiniment il va se faire chasser donc
autant le faire tout de suite
caillaud 5 est maintenant pour la foulée
2 on revient 2006 avec les blancs
position solide pas de faiblesses
regarder dans le camp blanc petites
faiblesses noires est cruciale
attention la colonne c'est mais voyez
que ces deux fous ici sont les gendarmes
de la colonne ces voix là c'est contrôlé
m même si on double ben on peut rien
faire voilà donc c'est pas très gênant
et d'ailleurs on continue à chasser les
tours pour montrer qu'on est fort sur la
colonne c'est faux quatre bateaux est
attaquée qu'est-ce que vous qu'est ce
que tu fais tours d2 voilà elle
abandonne la boue que l'on sait laisse
tomber ya rien à faire
alors attention là puisque si lecavalier
et bouge le foot attaque et donc des
coûts comme calais prend b5 sont
envisageables calibre en mécène apprend
cavaliers tout reprend attention ceci
dit et ce genre de manoeuvre parce que
qu'elle les prend b5
il peut y avoir foule et quatre
intermédiaires catapila tour c'est pas
tout à fait la même et si la tour bouge
après je peux envisager de prendre le
cavalier donc attention attention
faire attention mais car il prend des
scènes coupées 4 on peut aussi jouer
cavale et c7 et ont fait fourchette
contre une fourchette et à la fin on a
gagné pions donc attention
alors faut b4 voilà donc ici elle
anticipe ballan lève le fou de la delà
de l'action de la tour et la taux est
attaquée non seulement été fort soit
cool en s'éloignant des forces y soit
colonne des on oblige la torah revenir à
la maison voilà boom
voilà allez hop vatan voilà longtemps
les tours sont là on est c'est pas
demain la veille qu'on les doux qu'on va
les doubler déjà on n'a rien on n'aurait
même pas en sortir une donc de la
première rangée food est simple voilà
donc les noirs sont très forts pas de
problème il
bien que leur structure soit un peu
faible l'isolant ben ok j'ai un pion
faible mais tu peux rien faire de toute
façon c'est vraiment symbolique comme
avantage torah c'est un bien sûr la
dernière pièce qui jouait pas très
important qu'on ne sait pas quoi faire
renverser une pièce qui joue pas on
essayait de trouver une meilleure case
pour la placer la tour à y jouer pas on
l'amène sur la colonne sais c'est un peu
mieux et voilà simplement conteste pas
de problème on conteste h4 on prend de
l'espace ont contre l'éventuelle ghsr
contre la cage des scènes qu on se
libère une petite fenêtre pour le moins
bon coup logique on améliore un petit
peu à la position prend un peu d'avancé
on essaie de le prendre de l'espace x 3
ha ouais alors la classique 1 quand vous
avez une colonne comme ça et que
l'adversaire conteste et bien si vous
arrivez à attaquer c'est souvent par un
fou qu'on fait ça d'ailleurs bien les
l'adversaire obligé de céder la colonne
soit la tour revient en b1 mais c'est
très passif soit ce très certainement il
ya l entoure ces deux voilà les change
pas pas des changes pour ces 2
mais bon c'est pareil les blancs voient
là on n'est pas prêt on peut pas doubler
ici et donc attention quand même pour
ces deux et on peut pas chasser se fout
là on n'est rien pour attaquer on peut
jouer phocéen une possibilité problème
urgent c'est de jouer phocéen est comme
ça en cas de prisons reprendre la
tournée on a doublé
on a réussi à doubler nos tours donc
voilà il faut faire quelque chose
donc les rêves et les noirs prennent
tout simplement prise alors six heures
ça attaque le fou n'est ce pas là le
cavalier bouche la colonne donc on va
jouer le faux bond à la fossette
on ne met pas en d6 ou une jouerie
compte et notamment on gagne un temps
puisque on attaque le pion à 4 voyez
c'est important ça aussi un on enlève le
fou et en même temps gagne en temps on
perd pas de temps puisque un pion est
attaquée h5
on profite du fait que le fouet temps de
bien placé pour protéger ce pion h5 ce
puits en scène tient en perspective il
s'y tient en arrière cesser ses deux
pions voilà on peut pas bouger
maintenant c'est fini on a un petit oeil
sur la classe g 6
on sait jamais mais moi bien mettre une
pièce un g6 peut-être ont même si ça
ferait rien on papa un full un bon
s'attaquerait la tournée ça sert à rien
cette tour façon les a permis de rester
là elle a fini son travail
bon alors notez qu ainsi le roi bien
protégé f7 par wiseid plus tard on peut
chasser le cavalier et on pourrait faire
un échec du fouet ou valleroy voilà donc
tous viennent contrôler une case comme
ça sans risque voilà un pion bien placé
et voilà tour s'est vite c'est normal
vous voyez que les noirs avaient du coup
précis mais garde la le contrôle de
monsieur qui contre la colonne ballon
revient en d4 alors pareil les blancs
contrôle très bien la colonne ces
voix-là cavalli contrôle c2 le fou
contrôle c'est un donc on a la colonne
de manière symbolique et voilà web cette
voie là
c'est un coup logique 1 le pion aussi
c'est un bon mais un peu éloigné bon
c'est le roi qui vient qui vient servir
de soutien
c'est important que joue ce genre de
coups parce que ça si vous voulez ça ça
surprotège c'est une surprotection senim
d'aubisque inventé ce concept et un
niveau beach un grand joueur du danois
du 20e siècle et crier mon système avec
plein de nouvelles idées pour l'époque
la surprotection l'idée de la
surprotection c'est que ce four est
beaucoup plus libre c'est à dire que
maintenant il peut il peut bouger sur
cette diagonale sans risque de perdre 6
voilà et plus la pièce qui protège le
pion plus chacune des pièces et libre
voilà on peut par elle peut partir quand
je dis dans les autres s'occupent du
pion voilà donc ces idées ça libère les
autres pièces f3 alors f3 bons coups
extraordinaires non plus mais c'est un
bon coup ça d'abord un ça enlève la case
ou quatre pour le foie des reins
éventuellement ça contrôle aussi gk on
sait jamais ça permettra plus tard
peut-être de jouer g4 pour protéger h5
s'il est attaqué ce qui fait que c'est
plus le fou qui va s'occuper de la
défense mais le pion gk et enfin le roi
pourrait envisager de venir en f2 se
rapprocher lui aussi du centre voilà
donc où logique alors que f4 ont été
affaiblis sens parce que un petit peu
parce que bon c'est agressif mais bon çà
çà çà contrôle pas la case 2,4 notamment
voilà ça laisse la case de quatre
semaines et noir fu fu cette logique
l'intérêt de fawcett bon ben je comptais
le caïman c'est une chose de jeu
on ta caisse a en tout cas je contrôle
des quatre centrales et ça permet au roi
aussi devenir en recettes
j'ai dit alors peut-être plus tard ayant
un échec angers 6 est bon mais pascal
alors on sera content de venir et en os
est plutôt qu'en effet si ce mal placé
coin wave 2 voilà centralisée normale et
ours et 3 mai nord-est est activée y a
pas de danger juste faire attention pour
ces trois bons alors est-ce qui a une
idée derrière ce coup ce que je peux pas
m'en donner un visage et sacrifices en
trois rois prend le cavalier et protéger
deux fois on n'a pas grand chose donc
c'est un coût qui active la tour un
petit peu et qui qui pose les problèmes
peut-être un peu au blanc 1 10 ans aux
blancs bombés voilà ta pas de concevoir
d'autres trucs ont essayé de mettre les
blancs 6 millisecondes mais il n'y a pas
vraiment du doigt il ya trop de coups
possibles à f4 quand même voilà donc f4
quand même maintenant alors pourquoi la
pas l'avoir fait a vraiment bon mais
pourquoi pas là c'est vraiment une
histoire de choix c'était jouable avant
aussi un j'ai dit que c'était juste
c'est pas la même idée ça contrôle pas
les mêmes case mais f4 voilà j'attaque
le cavalier où il va céder longue
manoeuvre pour l'instant se passe pas
grand-chose partie assez équilibrée
cette faiblesse on va les blancs peuvent
pas en profiter vraiment donc foot est
roi
voilà alors hein c'est ce que je disais
un petit peu regardé up
si on avait rêvé à chasser le cavalier
et ben on à la cage et 6 grâce aux pions
h5
voyez donc c'est des coups comme ça des
petits coups qui ne trouvent leur
justification que beaucoup plus tard
alors bon maintenant ceci libon le fou
en échec alors on le roi varian set et
alors qu'il se fasse soigner tout bref
d'ailleurs les noirs le met tout de
suite en sept ans dix ans mais voilà tu
vois vous et si ça me gênait pas parce
que de soissons j'avais envie de venir à
sète déjà donc tu fais ce que tu veux
faux b to b on replace le fou c'est un
reclassement se fout sédiments sur ces
diagonales faisait pas grand chose que
c'est discutable parce qu'il attaque et
ce duo de pions donc alors c'est
peut-être l'idée d'ailleurs deux tours
ces trois avec avec le fou décès c'est
d'empêcher à 4 je me disais tout à
l'heure c'était quoi l'idée de
deux tours c'est 3 on empêche un petit
peu à 4 puisque le pion b3 serait
emprise et l'idée d' à 4 pour les blancs
s'étaient d'ailleurs si les noirs
prennent chez envisages tu reprendras 6
après plus tard avec le foot
donc voilà donc là alors vu que petro
est attaqué c'est ça marche plus grands
fauves quatre échecs
alors attention piège classique
si les blancs maintenant font b3 ce
serait une faute vous montre tout de
suite regardé parce que là on à la tour
c 3 d'où l'intérêt d'avoir des pieds
sales team et même si on sait pas trop à
quoi elle sert tout de suite qui
pression sur b3 ce qui fait que ça
bloque le pion montre bien mais bon
passons par ne voulait pas sûr qu'ils
veulent pousser question mais bon là si
les blancs jouent ça regardez mistake
puisque fou cran et oui je donne le fou
pourquoi parce que roy prend et le fou
et 3 n'est plus protégé donc je peux le
prendre avec la tour est au passage j'ai
gagné un pion un pion important
espérons maintenant laisser les blancs
comptent deux faiblesses olala c'est
grand mais là je conseille l avantage il
est significatif
donc ici attention flash 4 pas faire
l'erreur là de se dire je vais protéger
et non ça marche pas on croit aux deux
alors là on se dit mais alors du coup
c'est bien pour le noir ça je prends g2g
gagner un pion mais non ça marche pas
puisque si les bleu et noir prennent g2
améliorer tour g1 le fou doit bouger n'y
a pas de façon de le défendre et après
avoir laissé g7 qui tombe et laure là là
là c'est très très dangereux faut
absolument pas perdre ce pion g7
puisqu'après h6 devient très faible
surtout maintenant que j'ai joués 4
contre les casses de défense et c'est
très difficile d'aller défendre schiste
qui reste tomber aussi alors là il ya
une marée pions aussi qui reste avancer
très vite donc ce serait un avantage net
avec un gain en guerre à la clé un donc
attention il ya des pièges partout dans
cette position mais bon c'est des grands
maîtres un énorme et de très bon niveau
donc je vais bien sûr faux pas ce genre
de fautes et fautes 6 on vient et 6
et maintenant mais j'ai quatre on y va
alors là c'est l'idée que ces trois
pions joue presque contre enfin joue
complètement d'ailleurs même contre ce
duo-là la menace blanche maintenant
c'est de jouer g5 le fou n'a pas de
cadre si on donne le fou contre le
cavaillon l'a déjà dit dans nos la paire
de fou c'est pas toujours une bonne idée
hein
c'est même souvent une très mauvaise
idée
faudrait reprendre la tournée ailleurs
sans doute parce que si on prend du fou
y aurait fou échec en f3 en f3 pardon
qui prend la tour à tour de vous faire
attention mais sur g5 ça forcerait les
noirs à prendre on prend et là on a dû
aux deux pions contre 2 contre 1 donc on
a un pion passé potentiel est donc un
avantage à l'aileron davantage aller le
roi un pur aussi s'isoler bon qui
devient passé mais très loin 8 d'avancé
de toute façon ce secteur devient très
dangereux un plus à l'est pas facile
d'aller les chercher
et si on vient les chercher on risque de
perdre des points de l'autre côté alors
attention attention g4 les blancs jouent
de façon très active florette prescilla
donc l'énergie précis il donne le fou
quand même mais ça paraît ne pas être
une super nouvelle puisque fou prend des
4es alors j'attaque la tour et le pion
g7 donc ça c'est une défense attention
de précise défense de grand maître
regardez marianne vous y toujours de
très près si elle avait prévu avant mais
sur un tour à tour h3
voilà tout rage 3 alors ceci dit elle
aurait pu sans doute aussi joué tour g3
directement dont je trouve ça paraît
même presque curieux tour j'ai trois
attaques g4 tout de suite en cas de
prises angers 7
on prend g4 en cas de prise en a six eh
bien on prend on joue sans doute
attention il ya aussi fou h trois échecs
comprend la tour on le roi pourrait
venir attaquer mais c'est dangereux
c'est dangereux c'est dans le monde donc
c'est l'idée deux fois deux tours h3c de
créer un petit piège
évidemment tournage trois jeux menace
attention flash trois échecs au roi
ramasse la tour mais aussi attaque le
pion g4 avec le fou donc c'est une jolie
combinat de maria musi tout ça c'est
laisser assez créatif qui viennent faire
là quand même faut pas se tromper avec
les noirs attention piège tour c'est un
donc ifan vois le truc il n'y a pas de
problème ok tour c1 est donc je prends
la colonne sais je peux toujours prendre
g7 quand je veux
y'a pas de problème notamment on peut
pas défendre gc 3d si le roi vient en
effet cette défense g7 il ya tour c'est
cette le cavalier de clouer faut revenir
avec le roi pour protéger j'ai perdu du
temps
donc ce que je vais quand même perdre g7
et en plus j'ai laissé la tour venir ans
et 7 ils sont très très mauvaise idée
non regardez maintenant c'est l'idée des
noirs dans toute cette combine depuis
qu'elle a pris le cavalier regarder pour
simplifier pour pourquoi pas prendre un
petit avantage
soultz trois échecs bien joué leroy
bouge et maintenant pouf
je prends g4 et h5 est perdu donc là les
blancs prennent g7 mais simplement
prendre la tour et bilan j'avais un pion
joly alors est ce que c'est que ici
l'ifa nous n'avez pas vu cette
combinaison alors si elle a sans doute
vu on garde et elle va aller vers elle
est allée un coup plus loin
regardez up 3g 3 alors là le problème
une suivant si les noirs jouent un coup
comme faut deux pour n'y a pas d'autre
issue l'offre f5 sur foods 2 regardez
très fort attention piège tous sains et
regardez qu'est ce qu'il ya derrière il
ya le monarque
ce qui fait que quand le fou va jouer
mais d'ailleurs il va jouer
c'est un peu chaud il faudrait que il a
pas de case en fait mardi les prix alors
il faudrait que le roi ait attaqué le
fou est ce qu'on peut s'en sortir c'est
pas clair
non c'est pas mon père on fout en fait
voilà ça perd le fou donc faux de sa
paire info donc on peut pas jouer x 2
donc il reste le coût de la partie bien
sûr faux f5 voilà d'accord et là
regardez la manoeuvre rifan donc à la
calculer tout ça aussi un pas croire
qu'elle ait pas rentrer là dedans depuis
il faut prendre les 400 avoir vu
peut-être elle a vu un coup plus loin
que mariam ouzou ou pas parce que maria
avait peut-être vu aussi toute cette
suite mais elle s'est dit c'est quand
les meilleures chances les noirs peuvent
se tromper et il ya déjà des trucs à des
possibilités de perdre des points ce
genre de choses donc ici fou 3f sec
regardez maintenant mais si les noirs
prennent du plomb et 6,6 simplement
regarder très joli tour c6 et voilà boum
boum et c'est presque les blancs qui
sont mieux je pense ici parce qu'on va
prendre le pion à 6 ou le pion à six
salles or si les noirs jouent à cinq
il reste quand même perdre le pion jeu
le tout raciste mais je veux faire aussi
tout reprendre de toute façon la tour
n'a pas le choix il faut c'est changer
puisque elle a pas de gaz elle est pris
sur la colonne h et après tout reprend
fou prend et bien c'est les blancs qui
reste avec un fou contre un cavalier bon
ceci dit
n'a pas de plus en plus ça risque d'être
nulle quand même mais bon sait jamais
peut-être peut-être le blanc peut
essayer de pousser mais bon je crois pas
ceci dit voyez donc voilà donc sur fond
f5 simplement fou prend et au cas de
pions prend à tour ses six donc ce saut
pions ici bloquent l'action de la tour
sur la sur la 6ème donc la tour prend 9
sec et maintenant c'est l'heure donc on
fait tout reprend pour éviter sur ces 6
simplement on prend du fou et voilà donc
à la fin la combinaison les blancs
récupèrent leurs pions bon et c'était
quand même tendu donc vous avez vu quand
même que le très joli coup tours c1 et a
pas de panique
l'activation de la pièce a suffi pour en
fin de combinaison se retrouver à
égalité
donc c'est quand même joli joli manège
et la partie va continuer c'est à dire
que là on se dit bon ça va être nul ça
parce que là c'est fini il ya plus de la
faiblesse aussi séparé des pions le plus
avec 4 est aussi séparé que l'autre on
pourrait considérer que les blancs ont
l'hégire avantage du fait d'avoir le fou
contre le cavalier moi c'est ce que je
ce que je penserais même si bon les
noirs quand ils veulent ils jouent aux 5
c'est vrai qu'on voit mal comment on
peut faire quoi que ce soit mais
attention quand même les blancs aussi
menace ici de venir en c6 est quand même
de créer un problème ici si ses pions
bourges il peut se passer des choses
notamment ainsi ceux qui ont bougé bien
sûr cases noires et le fou tout de suite
va devenir très fort pour aller choper
ses pions la sueur cases noires il
devient une pièce cruciale plus
importante que lecavalier
pourquoi c'est plus important un fou
comme un cavalier dans ce type de finale
parce que le fupo à la fois par exemple
lancé cette imaginer que le puritain
sacre attaqué un pion et défendre
l'autre alors pour un cavalier voyez que
il est limité en terme de déplacement
assez difficile pour lui de protéger à
la fois ce pion et celui là il peut mais
il n'a pas beaucoup de place pour ça
c'est un peu plus difficile quoi
ce qu'on peut un peu figé un cavalier la
d'intérêt que si enfin il a plus
d'intérêt en finale si les pions sont du
même côté les appareils n'ont donc la
tour ses symboles a tranquille là les
noirs sont là les noirs propose la nulle
quasiment pour ces cinq dont ces cinq
propose annulé change le cavalier prend
et c'est nul bon c'est à la fois bien et
pas bien c'est bien de faire mieux avec
les noms un championnat du monde mais
bon le problème des mariages ou zouk
sait qu'il faut gagner
alors est-ce que lecavalier a des
chances de gagner s'est-il finale
pourquoi pas le roi est loin peut-être
il peut se passer des trucs par la 7e
cavaliers peuvent venir en d3 et menacé
de venir en b 4 mai le fou défendre est
ici sans doute non il peut pas
d'ailleurs un peu pas peut-être c'est ça
tout reprend cavale et prend menace
cahier des trois est le cas il vit en b
4 et tout de suite on a un problème il
faut bouger les pions alors si on est
obligé de bouger les pions de cavalier
peut gagner la bataille parce que il va
vite bouger c'est que le roi blanc ici
loin et loin des pions un don qu'il peut
se passer des trucs donc où il fan ne
prend pas de risques qu'un tour et fin
voile garde sa tour alors faut noter
imaginer que on arrive à échanger un
maximum de pions toile f1 regarder
notamment ben je peux jouer 5 1 plus
tard un pur pas tout de suite mais
sûrement si la tour bouge par exemple je
peux envisager de jouer 5 et c'est
d'éliminer un pion imaginez qu'on
élimine les pions soffin et bien le fou
n'a pu que se sacrifier contre le
dernier pion bat tours cavalli contre
tours ça ne gagne pas c'est nul et c'est
plus facile afin plus facile c'est nul
et alors que tours est fou contre tours
philidor ça gagne souvent ou en tout cas
c'est très difficile à défendre et il ya
des positions gagnantes il faut savoir
touré fou contre tours contre ne s'est
pas intuitif on se dit que ça fait nul
facilement non non non non c'est très
difficile à défendre
et c'est quasiment gagnant face et
galère il ya des positions gagnantes
c'est un peu technique il ya des
positions dont on s'est créé son mélange
bons essais à savoir donc mais là si les
blancs pourraient aussi se retrouver
avec touré cavale contre tours en cas
d'élimination des pions mais ça fait nul
ça donc ça c'est des trucs à savoir
quand vous êtes en finale
et si on sait pas ça bon on va pas jouer
les bons coups en finale parce qu'on
saura pas que les positions sont nulles
ou pas
donc c'est pour ça que sur du vent la tv
il ya d'ailleurs une série de vidéos
qu'on a fait avec ninon la championne de
france sur les finales que je voulais
faire parce que mon avis et c'est
fondamental
voilà c'est ce qu'il faut apprendre
avant même les ouvertures les finales de
base donc ici cavalli et 6 pour les
noirs
l'actif son cavalier montceau kayhan 17
était passif elle veut peut-être venir
en d5 et à venir pourquoi pas fillon
menacé de venir en b 4 onces et 3 à
titiller les pions la tour aussi aurait
eu envie de venir en c 2 1
on peut se demander d'ailleurs ici pour
osciller s'il est alors attendez hop hop
ici pourquoi les noirs n'aurait pas
jouer tout de suite d'un coup comme tour
ces deux voies retour ses trois échecs
mais tour ces deux avaient autour
séduire tout rêve de tout simplement
peut-être en cas de prise dans ce cas le
roi se rapproche des pions peut-être ses
salines bon en tout cas 4ème 6ème alors
qu'alexis là se pose pas de questions me
fans foulée 5
elle va éliminer le cavalier alors qu'on
se dit que le fou est peut être meilleur
peut-être le fait que le roi soit loin
des pions la tour est un petit peu
active peut-être je sais pas toujours
est il que les noirs jour f7 ressortir
du clonage et les limites alors là le
rat dans une finale qui est
techniquement nul ça c'est des grands
maîtres ce niveau-là et savent que c'est
nul on peut toujours faire des erreurs
mais il n'ya même pas que tu en avance
mais même avec des pieds on avance même
avec un pied en avant sur finale deux
tours c'est souvent difficile de gagner
voir c'est souvent nul pour pas dire que
c'est souvent mieux
on apprend donc là bon là on sait que
c'est techniquement nul donc en fait ils
fans ici assure au niveau championnat si
elle si elle joué pour le ciel était en
phase
d'égalité au championnat du monde
peut-être qu'elle aurait essayé de jouer
un peu plus avec le fou contre le
cavalier peut-être je ne sais pas b4
alors voilà on assiste à des manoeuvres
il va se passer des choses dont ces
quatre ya quand même du jeu tour f3a
alors ça c'est responsable ça donne le
pion b4 non ça ne donne pas puisque
regarder surtout reprend b4 qui est
quand même possible les blancs auraient
sans doute joué tour à 3 et surtour à 4
et bien tout simplement la prise
cette position est nul mais oui parce
que malgré le pion de plus vous savez
que le pion à il gagne pas contre le roi
donc de toute façon ses pions
nos carnets deux doublés ou cannet 3 ou
4 sur la colonne à il suffit que le roi
arrive en b2 et c'est fini alors à venir
faut pas qu'il reste des pions ici mais
ses pions là les noirs peuvent rien
faire ici parce que là il ya sylvie roy
f50 f3 et il faut il donc si on veut
passer faudrait il changer ce plan
d'abord et après c'est nul c'est nul
donc ça c'est archi nul donc c'est ça
l'idée des blancs avec b4 en fait on
invite les noirs entrer dans l'allumé
l'arrière music you peut pas rentrer
dans la nul à cause de la position dans
le match donc surtout rêve 3l faire f
cell voilà elle tente le temps de jouer
pour le guen quand même donc la cie
sportif alors pourquoi dans ce cas là
jouent qu'avec 6 et le permet au foot
c'est changer quand on le cavalier c'est
un peu paradoxal mais bon peu importe
tour à trois ont très bien et maintenant
tout 3 4 voilà c'est à dire qu'on prend
pas le pian bkp leurs trains ce n'est
pas la même parce que là on se crée un
petit pion passé alors cette finale
c'est encore une finale deux tours et
vous allez voir tout reprend 1,6 donc en
mai 4 les blancs on le donnait un pion
alors c'est plus un pion de doubler mais
c'est nul quand même voilà c'est qu'il
faut savoir cette position est quand
même nul
c'est triste à dire mais c'est comme ça
alors notamment mais vous allez voir que
on va avoir la fameuse position de
philidor en défense tour b 6 c'est très
bon coup alors ça c'est bien ça de
russell moi je trouve c'est pas mal même
si bon on aurait pu on peut tenter
hausse alors le problème ici c'est qu'il
ya quand même plus ou moins de la mine
de rien ce qui fait que même si on joue
aux 5
après on a envie de faire tomber trois
échecs ne peut pas on peut pas faire
trouver trop haché et si on sort de la
colonne on perd le pion bon alors il
faut savoir ici que si ses pions b est
assez change eh bien tout reppion contre
roy et tour c'est nul position de
philidor expliqué par philidor dans son
fameux livre l'analyse du jeu d'échecs
des des dix 777 alors ils expliquent pas
ça en 17 ans 49 il explique en 1877 dans
la deuxième édition du livre l'édition
complète et bien c'est philidor qui
explique la fameuse position de fidor
comment on fait nul en fait avec des
exemples voilà et c'est le premier à
avoir expliqué et on va la voir cette
position
roy le roi de 5
bref trois c'est qu'il faut que si vous
voulez après l'échangé il faut que pour
annuler la finale avec les blancs sur
pour annuler la finale 3 contre 3 et
pions il suffit nécessaire et suffisant
que le roi soit devant le pion et après
il faut connaître la manoeuvre parce que
évidemment si on connaît pas la
manoeuvre on va perdre quand même on
risque de perdre ça on perdra si on fait
n'importe quoi c'est sûr il faut
connaître la manoeuvre qui va avec mais
c'est nul
trois des cinq donc là l'idée de noir
ils savent que on peut pas parce que ici
regardez les noix on aurait pu
non je veux dire des bêtises ici ah oui
alors ici est ce que les blancs ah oui à
noter que les blancs peuvent pas jouer
le coup ici voilà c'est ça que je
voulais dire parce que je l'avais envers
n'ai jamais vu ça on peut pas jouer
après voilà on peut pas jouer ici avec
les blancs le coup à 4 qui a l'air
intéressant puisque les noirs peuvent
pas prendre 1,4 à cause de tour en tour
et on peut pas prendre on peut prendre
la tour menace classé tout reprend échec
et on a la position de filles dans sur
le roi va contrôler la quasi si il
revient
bon bah ça tout à l'heure donc à 4 est
intéressant mais ça marche pas parce
qu'il ya touré échec d'abord le roi
bouge et après je prends avec le pion et
le pion protège la tour qui est en b3 là
c'est plus la même parce que là j'ai
deux pions et c'est plus l'année c'est
plus la position classique
c'est peut-être mieux quand même je ne
sais pas trop mais ça va être beaucoup
plus dur à nîmes et 6 nuls alors donc si
on peut éviter c'est pas plus mal
donc ici roi f3 roi des 5 6 en août
gagnant je dis que c'est peut-être nul
mais c'est son nom
trois des cinq est là simplement run
trois voiles alors ce qui est important
donc c'est ce roi surtout reste devant
ce pion et que on arrive à échanger ce
pion contre celui là bien sûr faut pas
donner ce point gratuitement et c'est ce
que les blancs soit ils attaquent le
pion v5 soit il attaque l'autre pions
donc le roi va rester par là à la fois
pas trop loin de ses pions et devant le
pion de verre le humer 600 faut bien
essayer quelque chose
roi des rois des deux jeux peut menacer
maintenant à 4 puisqu'il ya plus
d'échecs alors s'il ya un échec en b2
mais j'attaque la tour et je peux pas à
prendre un quatre ans puisque l'auto est
attaqué c'est pas la même on croit des
deux je mens je m'enlève de la troisième
ligne ici qui me permet dans certains
cas de jouer au k4 à 4 envisageable même
si il ya d'abord eu 5 mais je peux jouer
tous ici qui attaquent le pion le pion 5
c'est possible aussi
donc la tourbe et deux échecs passés la
tourbe et 4 où on essaye on essaye à
trois attaques là tout un toit si
j'arrive à changer ce piot rang contre
celui là les blancs savent que grâce à
la position de philidor entourent roi
contre 3 tours et puis on sait nul entre
ses cinq tours aux 6 voilà la tour ne
peut plus attaquer là puisque attaquée
elle vient à eux 6 et hop tour 4 a tant
marqué que l'ici ainsi les blancs
avaient pris l'un est roi apprend tour
c'est perdant la finale de roi et
perdant deux pions passé suffit je vous
passe la technique je vous renvoie à
l'étude des finales ces perdants vous
avez qu'à essayer louga ici toro six
tours 4-3 ces deux
trois des quatre protection échec à ces
quatre échecs
trois des cinq tours b 6 mois je harcèle
les noirs tour ces quatre échecs
voilà alors à ça alors il s'était même
coup malin pour ces quatre échecs l'idée
tour ces quatre échecs
c'est certainement un des sites et les
blancs à venir en b2 mais s'il est roi
bien b2 et bien la tour ici coupe le roi
d'un scorpion passé peut avancer sans
que l'europe venir devant et là on
risque avoir par contre la position
gagnante de la finale deux tours c'est
plus la position de philidor qui permet
d'annuler donc se trompent pas il fait
doux elle sait que ce roi dont rester
pas loin du puy ont passé ce n est pas
passé assez simple forcément le pion de
5 été attaqués et voit la tour b 8
points 4 échecs et 4
tourbes et huit tours à cinq échecs en
c4 et voilà on attaque l'autre pions
c'est terrible
trois des cinq échecs à 4 tours de 8 à
toi mais il faut essayer quelque chose
donc est là elle prend tout reprend
position de philidor leroy et devant le
pire on contrôle bien les quasi s'il
peut pas être chassé ce qu'il faudrait
pour les noirs ces coupés seront arrivés
à mettre la tour prends ici que le roi
soit de l'autre côté
voilà qu'ils soient un peu coupé il est
coupé il ya des chances de gains alors
plus les lois n'a d'ailleurs plus c'est
facile à gagner et alors vous allez voir
la technique des blancs pour annuler
alors ouais f4s que les blancs les noirs
vont quand même pouvoir pousser leurs
pions
bref trois échecs 4,8 échec ça c'est
pour pousser le roi voilà c'est là qu'il
faut les infos les devants le pion
toujours devant le pion devant le pion
au f4 et maintenant voilà tomber trois
positions de philidor alors c'est celle
là la vraie position de philidor henri
dès la suivante
maintenant les blancs restent sur la
troisième ici et donc les noirs pourront
jamais avancer leurs droits
sauf à pousser le pion y poussent et il
poussera 1,3 menacera f3 et attention il
payera une menace de maths après
derrière mais justement dès que le pion
bien que dès qu'il y en ait trois à
l'euro est encore escales à ce moment là
la tour quitte la troisième elle part en
b vite élan à les noirs peuvent pas
empêcher des échecs des échecs des
échecs partout et ce qui fait que c'est
ingagnable e4 pour ces trois regarde et
voilà elle reste sur la troisième
position de philidor donc je vous
renvoie encore une fois un autre grand
ancien plus grand joueur français de
tous les temps
peut-être alors avec maxi match facile
alors maintenant qui quand elle nuancé
mondiale
on peut dire que là on n'est pas loin
mais bon philidor à l'époque c'est
vraiment le meilleur joueur du monde il
avait battu stamm mal syrien faut savoir
à qui l'avait battu il battait tout le
monde et de loin
et voilà et donc l'analyse du jeu
d'échecs il ya la position de philidor
ya aussi l'ouverture fini d'or bien sûr
mais la position philidor finale de
pions celle là il explique
merveilleusement bien donc c'est là
qu'on est là qu'on voit la grandeur du
bonhomme c'est dans sa capacité à
expliquer simplement des choses
compliquées que 3 et là regardez c'est
l'heure c'est que vous avez 10 pouces
voilà ça y est on pas voilà et là c'est
fini parce que si le roi maintenant
essayer de s'approcher pour menacer m'a
très bien mais là on va faire des échecs
perpétuelle échec échec et le roi n'a
pas il peut pas à se cacher mais aucun
endroit
ou alors il faudrait qu'ils viennent
mais s'il vient le pion il sera perdu
suffira après d'attaquer le pion il voit
là il est perdu il ya plus rien quoi si
le roi selouane évidemment complètement
foutu donc il ya un les noix les noirs
peuvent rien faire ici
si si ils défendent avec la tour béjart
sel quand même le noir on peut un peu
essayé de regarder la variante est ici
si les noirs essayer de se protéger avec
la tour on peut même commencé à harceler
en harcèle il n'y a pas d'endroit où
aller sur un sofa à 4 pour les ce cachet
ou alors faut mettre la tour devant donc
on met la tour devant maintenant tout
reprend on apprend voilà essahel vous
devez savoir que c'est nul 6 à 6 nuls il
faut venir ici
attention pas l'art ni lin et là
regardez maintenant sur voilà simplement
on vient là et c'est nul hop et pattes
voilà donc ici sur e3 tour c'est 8 a été
joué donc est parti nul voila on voyait
elles sont quand même allés jusqu'à une
position 2 nuls théorique
voilà avec cette fameuse position de
philidor donc c'est bien pour nous ça
nous a permis de réviser sa belle partie
je trouve c'est une des plus belles de
marianne zouk envoyé qu'elle a quand
même tenté un truc quand même un peu
complexe mais il fans un tout vu un
et vous avez vu comment elle s'est
magnifiquement comportez pas de problème
avait calculé quelques coups plus loin
elle a vu qu'elle a fait récupérer les
pions avec de l'activité donc est là et
puis elle a bien jugé la finale
attention d'où l'importance de connaître
les finales parce que si vous connaissez
pas donc ces finales fondamentale et
bien vous pourrez pas faire ces
combinaisons de milieu de partie parce
que vous saurez pas si à la fin vous
êtes gagnant perdant nul et c'est donc
si c'est d'où l'importance de connaître
les finales avant d'étudier même les
niveaux les milieux de jeu et de
connaître les milieux de jeu avant dépit
des ouvertures en fait faut étudier tout
à l'envers de ce qu'on fait d'habitude
ou de ce que 110 ans les débutants
d'habitude il faut commencer par les
maths est remonté pour savoir à la fin
qu'est ce qu'il vaut mieux choisir comme
début oui faut faire l'opération inverse
à mon sens voilà ça reste un avis
personnel
voilà donc merci de nous avoir suivis
pour cette émission
donc c'était la septième partie du
championnat du monde
u10 fans ou mènent toujours 2,2 points
et donc il reste deux parties
marianne2 si tu dois gagner les deux
pour respirer je voulais tie break bon
mission quasi impossible mais pourquoi
pas ce serait ça serait un
extraordinaire mais bon ça reste se
terminer quand même à la prochaine
partie à moins qu'elles sortent quelque
chose vraiment de complètement inattendu
à bientôt sur au diagonal tv pour donc
la suite de ce championnat du monde
au revoir